this past weekend and we got let's go
[Music]
hello it's Monday
it's Monday your little Chinese bomb
pops it's hot as hell and it's wet as
hell still out there for a lot of people
so let's take you out of that for a
little bit huh come with me for a little
bit come sit on Daddy's knee come sit on
Daddy's dusty Ashley and me and listen
to the sounds of this this old dirt
snake come listen to the slither of this
old dirt snake as I go just slipping
through the dirt thank you guys for
joining me it's Monday September 4th
it's Monday September 4th it's Labor Day
it's Labor Day and and we're here we're
here we made it we made it to another
Monday congratulations to you I spilled
coffee all over this desk so I got my
elbows in coffee you know maybe I'll
start to tan my skin maybe our skin will
get it a little bit tan I'll be able to
get a roll out here in Los Angeles tough
time out here for a white guy tough time
out here for a white guy good to be here
this morning thank you guys for joining
me on this past weekend and what
happened this past weekend I'll tell you
this I'll tell you this dude what
happened this past week is I was doing
some manscaping last week I had an
audition at an audition going in to
audition for a film for a lead role and
I decided to do a little manscaping
because I'm the kind of guy who I'm good
you know I'll be on task a little bit
and then I'll get to you know I'll have
40 minutes to get where I'm going I'll
jump in the shower
be out in seven minutes but don't be
standing there in front of the mirror
and instead of just getting ready
I'll see like um you know sometime you
see on your on your eyelash eyebrows are
on your run your crotch you see like a
long hair you know one of them long
extraneous hairs you know
kind of like if you've ever seen a
picture of like a private school
basketball team in like the sixth grade
it's all white kids and you have that
one tall long black kid that's on the
team and that's like that hair you will
see you'll see just that one that's one
of these is not like the others you know
and not in color I'm just talking about
in length and so I saw one of those I
was like oh I'm gonna clip this thing up
you know daddy gots a pair of uh daddy
gots a pair of all organized sharp
swords here scissors and I'm gonna clip
this thing down I'm gonna take control
and let's show this young follicle down
here by my wiener and everything who's
boss and I clipped it and I just kind of
wasn't paying attention I guess enough
and I clipped a little bit and it's
gonna sound vulgar and it's it's not
gonna get any more graphic than this but
I clipped into my scrotum and I'm a
squat and they do call it squat and I've
played it and Scrabble as before as
squat and I and I clipped into my
scrotum with these you know little
clippers these scissors and man you
don't think you have a lot you think you
kind of don't know what's in your
scrotum let's be honest a lot of times
you know people say oh my nuts but
there's a lot of stuff going on in there
if you really ever spend some time with
your scrotum and a lot of you guys
probably don't you know a lot of you
guys just running around just kind of a
hunt not a hundred percent sure what's
in your nut bag I don't do that you know
I'm not like that I know what's in my
nuts hat you got them vein you got the
kind of them eight Vantage a little bit
those kind of feels like you're nuts
each I wearing these kind of soft kind
of hats
you got some nut fat there's some fat
around your nuts light kind of thing of
fat around each nut and you got some
other stuff in there I think you got the
vas deferens whatever those are that
could also be it could also be a British
rock band but but anyway you also have a
good bit of you got some you know some
blood in there and this thing started it
was pretty much leaking out and I had to
be at this audition and I'm not gonna
get real graphic and I'm sorry I have
out of the gate but I just have to tell
you what happened so
I am alarmed I put a napkin on it hard
press that napkin and I got a chip clip
you know this chip clips who used to
close up a bag of chips sometimes you
get some chips you get your hand in the
bag of chips you open the bag of chips
you don't want them all you know
now some people open a big bag of chips
eat them all and don't realize that they
even have chip clips in the world that
chip clips exist but if you if you're
still doing that I've got a I got to
tell you something that they have a chip
clip and that's where if you don't want
to eat an entire big bag of chips
because you shouldn't you know those
days are long gone I feel like health
wise so I hit this chip clip put it on
basically almost squat with this napkin
and now hightailed it out to the
audition got him to the audition and I
had to tell him right when I got there I
was running late I'm sweating I'm
nervous I had to tell him you know
because first of all I go in there I'm
worried that if any kind of red coloring
starts to show up on my pants you know
if I'm you know kind of having a little
bit of you know I don't to be graphic
here but if if I'm having a little bit
of I some iron drip if you will because
of blood has iron in it if I'm you know
sprinkling Payton platelets out of my
pants a little that they are going to
get scared or they're gonna think that I
have a menstrual cycle which is okay I
guess these days it's okay if a man has
a menstrual cycle I mean he'll I know
some real [ __ ] out there you know in
this room fellas it's really running
around as some real macho's especially
out here in uh in Los Angeles you know
but but I don't think to the point where
they expect a man had just be surprising
people with this uh you know a surprise
minstrel cycle so anyhow I had the chip
clip gone chip clip on did the audition
and that was uh that was a hectic gave
so then I was laid up I was laid up for
about two days and I started getting
depressed and you know when you can't be
active depression that's when it finds
you you know because depression is like
a um depression is like uh it's kind of
like uh mmm it's a bit like uh I'm gonna
say a mosquito because mosquitoes they
kind of hang around they mill around
but then when you don't when you don't
expect it that's when a mosquito coming
get you what is that oh that's a
mosquito and that's when they come and
get you when you don't when you don't
expect it you know what is that oh
that's a mosquito
were you expecting it no I wasn't you
know and that's when mosquitoes come get
you and that's how depression is ma'am
and if I lay around I get too stagnant
that's when depression starts for me and
and I started getting depressed man for
a whole day I laid in bed you know
tending to my bag you know you're my nut
sack and making sure everything was you
know Cavalier down there and it was it
was alarming man it that is an alarming
time because that's where your body is
holding your future your next level the
next level of you your reincarnate is
housed in that bag so some people think
you're walking around us with your nuts
no you're walking around with your
family with your son with your daughter
twins maybe or transgender person all of
that is in your nuts I mean it it's
striking to believe but that's all in
your nuts right now I mean it's crazy to
think that right now if you're not to
make probably and this is your facts I
think you're not to make 200 million
sperm a day you got to figure six
million of those sperm are probably
transgender so everyone right now every
man running around has probably about
six million transgender sperm right now
between their legs
six million TGS right between their legs
right now so just kind of interesting to
think about it that way but yeah man I
had attended myself had to put salve on
him I had a couple cans of good salve in
there and I just started putting that
salve on and then put some gauze and I
put a sock around my bag and I just
socked up my bag and you had to take
care of yourself like that it was really
old-school kind of I had to take care of
my body you know because that's my
future that's my future but I'm wearing
a golf shirt I have on a golf shirt
today if you're on the youtube you can
see it I have a golf shirt on I don't
play a lot of golf I think I could
though I see men play it you know I see
sometimes I've been invited to some of
these fans here get-together these
fellows are out there doing golf you
know in it so everybody dresses a little
bit it almost look everybody dresses
like there are adults that are gonna
maybe be looking for Easter eggs
you know and everybody's like trying to
be friendly and have beers and stuff but
also everybody's thinking about maybe
banging each other's wives are making
love to each other's wives but but it
looks fun sometimes I've played a few
games almost killed a famous golf
designer a famous golf course designer
one time what was his name
die I thought his lesson was die and
that's not a joke I thought his last
name was actually dying anyhow so I got
a little depressed man I got depressed I
laid in bed I started watching episodes
have disappeared when I get depressed I
start to notice what do I do because
then I can tell if I'm depressed
sometimes I can't even tell so what do I
do when I'm depressed I watched shows
about disappeared people people that are
missing and disappeared as a show where
in the beginning somebody's missing and
at the end somebody's still missing
knock knock who's there not this person
somebody's still missing and that's uh
and I guess there's something in that
that at least at least I know where I am
you know at least I'm better off than
this person that is missing at least I
know where I am you know and that makes
me feel pretty good I guess you know at
least it's one thing at that low level
of where I'm feeling makes me feel still
kind of okay so what else man what else
do ya just hey you know I got a little
bummed out what else is going on in the
news North Korea people talking about
North Korea here's what I have to say
about North Korea first of all bring
bring it on if you want some of it we
got some of it okay oh what's this over
here this is some of it and if you want
some of it we got some of it because
here's the thing we've already beaten
you guys before okay I can hit up about
720 senior citizen facilities and I got
about probably thousands and hundreds of
thousands of senior men in there who
would happily go round - okay who were
out there in the Korean War who out
there getting dirty under mr. Truman
not afraid to get back out in the sand
all right I got about uh probably seven
hundred and twenty-five thousand senior
citizens about ready to put guns on
their walkers and sacrifice themselves
and get out there and go at it right one
more time
so I'm trying I'm sorry to get fired up
but but I'm also tired of being scared
about North Korea North Korea is not
gonna do anything to America or I don't
think to anyone because they have
everything to lose they're happy right
now they're North Korea nobody knows
what they're doing
they're up there playing games you know
I read an article one time that they
were doing human whack-a-mole that the
big you know the Pied Piper up there
King King John Kent Kim Jong is doing
the he does human whack-a-mole we had a
whack-a-mole thing built he'll have
human Koreans dress up in mole outfits
scoot around pop up out of the holes and
he hits him with a big deal you know a
big mallet is that [ __ ] up yet is dude
is that also awesome is [ __ ] yes it is
as well two things you know but I'm not
scared of North Korea I'm not scared of
North Korea dude but I've had a week man
I've had a weekend you know I'm going
through some emotional stuff you know I
had to meet up with the man this week in
the park to talk to talk with him you
know I'm in therapy okay I'll say it I'm
in therapy I'm not of ashamed about
being in therapy I'm trying to get to
the bottom of my brain some of y'all
sittin out here milling around the top
of your brain like a little brain babies
well guess what I'm a brain daddy
I'm down in the bottom of my brain
looking for myself so obvious I met up
with an old man in a park to this
weekend you know that's where I'm at
but good to be here happy Labor Day to
you guys we didn't come out with the
patreon people asked about patreon we
didn't come out with it last week and I
know I've told you that I would but
because of the donations in Houston I
just felt I felt that it wasn't right so
we'll do it we're gonna try to get it up
tonight or tomorrow so it'll be out this
week and it'll be out when you want to
go support patreon or patreon and
support this past weekend because I'm
gonna get this podcast to better and
better levels we're building the studio
we're gonna have guests soon we're gonna
try some residency's with co-hosts
sidekicks so we're open to new things
it's just take it take so it's a slow
build a lot of things were slow builds
you know think about something that was
a fast build where is it now probably in
a fast build graveyard thank you let's
hit the news we did North Korea [ __ ]
them [ __ ] North Korea dude I'll say that
I'm sure there's some good people are
they're not denying the people but you
know what I'm saying when you play when
one team plays another team I'm not
thinking about the players I'm thinking
about the teams and if they wanna they
wanna talk shop then welcome nice
hardware baby that's the shop I'm
talking hardware what else a guy died in
Burning Man a guy died in Burning Man a
guy hi got high was lifted up you know
I'm saying cooking his own spirit grits
on them drugs and on them dopes and ran
into a fire and you know what at first I
was like [ __ ] only one guy because part
of me is like lets roast have to for
half the squad up there you know half
the squad are these frickin fake miracle
Muppets out there on that dust looking
for themselves you want to find yourself
get out get out in your dirt stay off
the dust and I'm sorry I know I'm
getting fired up this weekend I'm fired
up man I'm fired up on this Monday a guy
died in Burning Man
they said he was on acid and MDMA and he
ran into the fire and you know what man
I've been on acid okay
I did once I asked one time and stole a
bunch of boat radios and I'm trying to
install them into regular vehicles
stupid stupid playing what else did some
ass he cooked a pizza and a drier one
time I used to know how long it took it
was a medium that's all I remember
but it works but it does take a while
got naked in my friend's yard mom and
his mom caught me out there honking my
car horn to a song that was on the radio
so I've made some poor choices on acid
but this guy ran into a fire but I'll
say this when you're on drugs sometimes
you do feel closer to a higher power
and maybe that's not a bad way to go you
know a lot of times we have old people
or young people whoever that when
they're dying when they're heading to
this to the to another realm when
they're hopping world's if they believe
in a higher power if they believe in a
warp zone you know if they believe in
heaven then they're then they're then
they're fired up you know they're going
there but why not have them be on drugs
if you're on drugs you already are
you're gonna be keyed up when you get
there or do you think that the natural
high of that experience of going of
going to that another world is a high
enough and then maybe the drugs would be
scary
I don't know but heck I could almost you
know a couple hits a mush you know a
couple you know cans of however they
serve in them cans of mushrooms and
psychedelics and couple hits acid and
I've had some bad experience with acid
and I'm gonna shame too Mike my times
you know I remember one time we did a
much acid with this girl and everybody
was people some people locked her in a
room and was dripping dripping hot water
on her warm warm water not hot water
warm water you know it was kind of it
wasn't this violent thing it was more
like a this sort of kind of Lord of the
Flies ish kind of romantic sort of Edgar
Allan Poe you know just children being
under dopes you know children with their
brains under the pressures and under the
you know the the tricky fixins of dope
you know my buddy slid a hit of acid
into a girl's vagina one time vag if it
needs to call it and that's just
tripping via vagina when you you know
lock a girl's vagina up with a hit acid
and you know now way she won't she'd
kind of relax a little and party a
little bit you know and see spirits with
her eyeballs you know that way she could
close her eyes and still be watching
television you know surfing her own
brain channels and sometimes that's the
beauty about some of those drugs but I
wonder if the man could feel the fire I
wonder if he was so high on the drugs
that did the pain well you know I just
wonder how much did that change his
receptors what was coming in on that
pain you know when it was he on the
paint whether we're there were there
surfers on the on those pain waves or
was it just it was it just comfortable
water I'm just wondering how that came
in on him you know and he's charred up
you know they said he took him to the
hospital he almost lived but maybe
that's a thing you know hi dying get
somebody high as [ __ ] and then pull the
plug on them I wouldn't be surprised if
that becomes a new thing you know I
can't believe that uh that cremation and
burial are the only two options for when
you die what sounds like the worst
restaurant ever only two ways to cook it
I want to be grilled brother yeah you
heard about Allen yeah
they sauteed him yeah they sauteed him
over it heavenly pastures I want to be
all gratin how about that Oh daddy's
showing up in the next realm with cheesy
patate that's how I'm gonna die stuffed
I want to be baking stuffed you show up
at my funeral boy I got six hits a bacon
flying out of my beak maybe a couple
olives like damn Theo knows how to go to
heaven with some flavor
don't embalm me with damn embalming
fluid throw something fancy inside of me
that you who remember you who chocolate
soldier put put a beverage inside of me
you know something that means something
just sick of you know I'm just sick of
these options let's expand our minds I'm
sick of these options you know you can
oh you can only go to heaven if you got
um you know you can only go to heaven if
you got embalming fluid or if you've
been cremated I don't want to be
cremated
all right skewer I want to be on a
skewer with an apple in my mouth
let's just let's it lets evolve guys we
should evolve in all types of ways you
know so just a lot on me man but I could
just uh I went to a funeral today
you know I guess to be honest with you
guys I went to a funeral a friend of
mine and not like a best friend but
certainly a friend or a guy you know a
guy really you know a friend his father
passed away so I went to the funeral and
I wasn't sure at first if I should go I
just but then I was glad that I went you
know I think it's hard to know sometimes
and I've always had a tough time I've
had an awkward gauge in my own life
socially awkward of knowing what things
to show up at and for whom like I used
to go to christenings for people I
barely knew you know when they had
family christenings and stuff in their
family I remember being like some in the
early 2000 being some in some people's
family photos that I'd only met like one
time at a bank and then I am you know at
the end of this picture when they're
babies getting christened and just some
awkward [ __ ] like that so you got to be
careful you know when you don't know
events to show up at but it was touching
man it was touching to see people share
their love and their feelings I'll you
know my buddy talked about his dad and
it was a surprise it was just you know
his dad wasn't well but it was a
surprise death and honestly like it
brought back feelings of my own when my
own father had passed and I know I'm not
trying to get down on you but you know
it just brought back some feelings you
know being young and just
what it's like when somebody leaves and
I just know that I would have probably
felt a lot more excited if I had known
that my father was chargrilled or
blackened you know or caramelized then I
know that they just cooked him down and
put him into an urn and you know that I
also want to say I don't like white
supremacist I do not like them I do not
like them in a house I do not like them
with a mouse I also do not like black
supremacists I do not like Asian
supremacists
I do not like people that only play
street fighter and no other game
extremism we got to shut it down I've
become kind of a little bit overwhelming
how people just I'm just sick of how
every has to be right everybody UK
there's no other way it's it's
ridiculous to have to be right
you can't everybody cannot be right
think about that it's impossible so why
some people still think that that's
realistic that that's their way or the
highway everybody's got to give
everybody's got a fold everybody's got
to show a couple of their cards man it's
just it's just beyond me but I had quite
a weekend man I had quite a week of you
know thinking about life cutting into
Mon ballsack you know a lot of men never
never go inside their own balls
not this guy you know a lot of men you
know don't want to be out at funerals
ice went out there showed up you know
did it did it did it so what else guys
what else what else can I tell you guys
about right now still a lot of love out
to the people in Houston I know that's a
tough thing going on the NFL is back I'm
excited about that
feminism sorry but once again we're
gonna have to ask you ladies to step
aside while we play fantasy football I'm
so excited about football man I'm so
excited about it I got I'm in two
leagues they got one more draft coming
up I'm excited and people are like what
players you gonna get out David
Johnson that's my go-to guy and if I
could have anybody else on any team
would be Michael Thomas for the New
Orleans Saints but yeah I guess it just
like at St time and I've had a lot on my
mind a lot of my heart and it's a crazy
week you know I've been in therapy
people are talking about global warming
it's so hot right now in LA that all
anybod people are sweating this girl the
other night out of the blue she's like
hey touched my leg Oh
sweating like that time I bought a bunch
of that Canadian viagra's and all they
did was make my legs and ankles sweat
and my legs swell up I don't think I got
an erection but geez Christ my was just
my leg was just one long thigh from the
toes to the hip no knee no ankle just
sweating I mean it was unbelievable I
think it just made you retain salt in
your legs yeah yeah just hot man hot as
hell people tell my global warming you
know scary people think it's the end of
the world I think mother nature's kind
of mother nature's gonna come and beat
somebody's ass I believe it I believe it
you know mother nature is gonna come and
beat somebody's ass and I hope she takes
out a few of these news networks that's
what I hope because these people are
just ruining [ __ ] my day would be a lot
better if there weren't some news
network in the distance yelling about
how horrible everything is but when I
look around people are doing okay and it
would just be nice and on if we could
focus on the fact that we are doing well
you know then I got food in my mouth you
know and we can move onward all right
let's take a couple of calls man I'm
gonna tell you guys I'm headed to Austin
this weekend I will be at the cap city
comedy club you can come and see me and
love me or hate me and that is this
Wednesday through Saturday and then the
following weekend
September 14th through 17th albeit
hilarities in Cleveland and then I'll be
a stand-up live in Huntsville and that
is November 16th through the 19th
oh and I got to tell you this good news
the movie that I clipped my nuts and
then went in an audition for they
offered me the part so that's pretty
exciting you know but we'll see
we'll see some of those things you know
you never know what's gonna happen in
the universe out here things go to
fruition but you know it just shows you
man when you cut in your own balls
you still get out there and do your work
you know and happy Labor Day let me tell
you about a couple jobs I've had that's
what I wanted to tell you guys
hold the line one second I got a plug in
my computer hold on all right I'm back
I'm BAC K a couple of jobs that I had
I'm going to tell you about this happy
Labor Day I'll say that and I want to
tell you briefly about a couple of jobs
that I had so one of my earliest jobs
was working at a pizza parlor called
BJ's and everybody knows BJ's means blow
jobs but this place just meant BJ's and
it had they had some cards on there and
that meant blackjack so I'm guessing the
best with the B and the J stood for
Black Jacks and I was a um pizza maker
and cleaner basically everything
[ __ ] work I was the lowest guy on
the totem pole used to make pizzas now
one of the assistant managers was a
born-again Christian he was born and
reborn and unborn and over born double
born I mean just a little zygote for
Christ by the end of it all and this
beautiful creature didn't know anything
about pop culture and he used to wear
Garfield t-shirts all the time and what
we would do is me and this other dude
who was on methamphetamines and this
other dude mouth my coworker he would
always have his pizzas rolled faster
than me right he'd have his pizza done
you know in two seconds you know and
they'd be like you need to the manager
would call me in the office you need to
do your pizzas fast as this guy and I'm
like whoa this guy is on drugs and the
money you're paying me I can't afford
the drugs that he's on so unless you
raise my pay I'm not gonna be able to do
drugs and compete
and be competitive here in the in the
pizza workplace so and this dude like I
would barely have my dough rolled out
and he would have his folded it into
like a swan you know like this dude was
damn you know Vincent van dough on that
on that yeast you know on that on that
flowering yeast but it was captivating
to be in that environment and I like
this job was uh it was probably my first
job in a real business you know and this
is post HAMP's this is after I sold
hamsters and guinea pigs and this is
after I cleaned out wishing wells and
this is after I used to Brett I broke
into a man's house and just stole stuff
from him one time and that was it's not
really a job but you do end up with you
know some money and some goods and and
you don't you know and so it's kind of
like a job but anyhow so we would make
up fake pizza orders for this for this
born-again Christian assistant manager
on Sunday and we would have orders like
Danny Glover and he would take him out
into the middle he would take the orders
out there five or six pizzas for Danny
Glover
I don't know lolled Man River old
Military Road or something he would go
out there take the pizzas come back an
hour later and there was no wrong
address no Danny Glover and then we
would eat the pizzas while he was going
we would drink and we would deep-fry
everything in the deep fryer and eat it
and that was a really good time that was
one of the best times that I had over
there doing that kind of work also we
used to work at a insurance company
where my job was to send documents my
job is to send paper products to other
insurance companies we ran a supply room
that supplied other smaller insurance
companies with documents they needed to
carry out business and big business so I
would mail out these documents well one
time I went in there on a bunch of
mushrooms and actually dated one of the
ladies daughters that worked in there
beautiful lady named Miss Trudy and I
stood at her daughter sweet gal and I
one time I ate a bunch of mushrooms in
there took my clothes off in the
mailroom then they had a door so I could
be in there by myself I'm in their mail
and you know putting stickers on stuff
right in the dresses stamps doing mail
what's this mail where's that go Oh
in the mail you know handling business
mail business and the thing that
happened was this
I got geeked out on some mushrooms and
mailed all of my clothing to one of the
smaller insurance companies so then I'm
in this mailroom had to literally make
myself some clothes even though I just
could have opened this box it was coming
up on time when the mail had to be due
so I was embarrassed like you know if I
don't if I don't this box it's gonna
look you know it's that they're gonna
come in here and thinking like what the
hell's going on so I made myself a
clothing out of paper made myself some
paper basically a skirt and not a shirt
but kind of like a shirt and then I've
got all the male products ready waited
for the male dude to come sign them off
to him mail my clothes to some insurance
company never saw him again
and and then I lost my job probably
about six weeks later but yeah you know
it's Labor Day and we've all had some
type of laborious time and that's
something I want you to call in and hit
the hotline for for next week is hit the
hotline and let me know about a job that
you had man let me know about something
that on this past Labor Day that you
were celebrating not working anymore one
other job I had I'd say real quick I
work on this farm and I had to get every
year they would cut the grain the corn
or they yeah they would cut the corn and
some of the these things that they would
store it in over the winter the snakes
would get in there and hide in there
because it was kind of warm it was out
of elements so then at the beginning of
the new farming season I had to get in
there and clean these things out and get
the snakes out and there were snakes and
rats and dude imagine somebody just put
you in the middle of a big blown metal
container and said all right I'll be
back in a few hours you got a there are
rats and there are snakes in here and
you need to get them out and people like
Game of Thrones
well I mean this was it was
this was violent dude and you being
there with a shovel or sometime I take
the wrong tool in there one time I was
in there with a pickaxe all day fighting
these animals right well guess what put
a couple of holes in the bottom of this
big holder so I mean definitely costs
those guys probably most of the money I
made that year by using a pickaxe to try
and battle mice and snakes so yeah some
poor choices in my and my work days but
you know what that's God's plan for me
that's what I'm gonna say what else
all right let's get to some calls man
let's take a few calls right here I
appreciate you guys for it in the
hotline you know it's good stuff and I'm
happy that you guys are hitting it the
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three let's take this
call right here whoo the old barn bells
on
I only got you on the hotline here
I'm calling down here from Nashville
Tennessee whoo Nashville beautiful thank
you for calling buddy there's a tornado
warning out right now the weather is
looking kind of rough but you know
whether it's kind of bad down there in
Houston town we're praying for all them
people down there as well I just wanna
let you know you wanting to raise some
money for this first disaster well I'm
here to tell you buddy next time you're
in Nashville Tennessee your honor she's
gonna be in Huntsville I will be in
Huntsville dude and I hope this did it
in a pedophile because I am an adult so
if you don't think I'm you know I'm a
child cuz I'm off his books at the just
at my age alone onward buddy you me on
the basketball court one on one night
guarantee I will whip your ass in that
basketball game oh you and me one on
quote this guy sounds like Matthew
McConaughey Louis doesn't he you and me
one-on-one on the basketball courts okay
I could do this maybe we have to think
about what the wage is and I guess the
money will make it a pro Cee'd that goes
to to to some charity down there onward
you can fame it
you can put it on periscope Facebook all
that [ __ ] raise the money for it
well raise little money okay all right
man I accept that challenge whenever I
come down to Huntsville we'll get into
that I appreciate that man that's good
thinking and a lot of people are doing
great things I mean I spoke to a buddy
of mine in Houston the other day and he
said that they that they that that he
was going back to work and people in his
area were going back to work that
locally they that he was unable to even
go volunteer when he and his friends and
went and signed up because all the
shifts were full that they weren't
accepting any more water they weren't
accepting any more diapers and I know
that was just the other day but it is
it's just amazing to see how people are
helping out and I think that that's one
thing it's it's nice to see in the wake
of all of this you know that human
beings when they get a chance to be
human they're choosing to do that and
that's not something that happens on the
internet you know that's not something
that social media you know there's some
stuff out there yes they're running the
charities through social media and stuff
like that but the hands-on hey the hand
on hand helped you know the
heart-to-heart help that's happening in
the streets and that's what's amazing to
see and that's what humanity is you know
we've just become these online creatures
where we're not human online you know
why because we're not because you're not
even a human then you're electronic
there's something else going on but it's
amazing to see that when humans get a
chance to be human especially in a city
that is diverse like Houston Houston's
got some diversity that people are
helping each other out and people are
working together you know and it's easy
and it's the it's great to see it happen
in Texas to a state where people you
know are always like oh Texas you know
they're gun toting you know Republican
and they get this bad rap I feel like
from a lot of people well guess what
Texas is showing America just how good
people can be and I know there's a few
bad eggs down there but you know what
overall you know people aren't pulling
up to each other when they're drowning
in these waters and asking them who they
voted for you know and then you still
have these
orders that show up down there and like
weld are you happy with how Trump are
you huh do you think get that [ __ ] out
of here you know why go down and just
make misery I don't understand it I will
never understand it oh if the aliens
come here do it and they're trying to
[ __ ] everybody I hope they start with
half of these news networks or most of a
man it's just we're better than that
we're better than they make us out to be
but I'll take that challenge brother
will do something hit me up on social
media or hit the hotline again let me
know a little bit more information and
we'll throw it down there there me versa
Matthew McConaughey call him but he got
that wild lisper dude he got that crack
daddy Lisp and I love it and you know
and I'll even watch you smoke a little
bit a couple grams if you're trying to
play if you trying to ball out after the
game do to celebrate your loss
we'll raise a little money all right
let's get to some calls man let's take a
few calls right here the show I've been
watching you since the MTV days hey
Melissa
thank you for calling my question was a
problem I'm antisocial judgemental with
people as soon as I meet them I start
picking them apart in my head I don't
like anything about him normally not be
much of a problem but I'm a blogger
oh okay so she's a blogger and she's
judgmental huh something you should have
a job then that's what's on word I need
to be social for my career
I do too these thoughts sometimes need
to tell us when you see me on there how
much I just five everybody around me the
only people I've seen you to like like
old ladies and comedian neither of those
are in my target audience so I was
hoping if you give me some advice on how
to get past that and be a little more
social and interested actually and
meeting people and talking to them yeah
well I appreciate you calling I would I
try to be curious that's what I try to
do when I get really judgmental and look
we're all judgmental and I'm
stereotypical and sometimes I was
talking to buddy the other night he's
tell me not to be so stereotypical but
I'm like I think that's a survival skill
you know at a certain point you got to
make some choices you got to group
people together you know and every now
and then somebody will surprise you
but sometimes you know I feel like eight
out of ten times people won't you know
so I do get stereotypical boy I think we
all battle with it being judgmental it's
so easy it's almost it's natural
I think it's natural for us to be that
way but how to get out of it I say try
and be curious
instead of like [ __ ] less I'm leaving
like sometimes I'll be listening to
somebody and my brain I said Doug man
I've heard this a million times
why am I even listening to this [ __ ]
person but instead trying to be like
well maybe this person will say
something different maybe this will be
different this time
or maybe this person needs me to listen
to them you know I think about trying to
listen I think about trying to be
curious instead of being judgemental be
curious if you just stay curious like oh
well I wonder what they're gonna say
maybe they'll tell me where there's a
buried treasure you know maybe they'll
tell me that they have a rare species of
bats or maybe they'll tell me that they
you know that they are having babies and
never had sex
you know maybe somebody'll have a secret
for you so that's what I say just trying
to stay curious and that's sometimes can
get you out of that judgment be it's
hard it's hard especially because
sometimes we just think we're better we
think we know it all you know but good
luck good luck with it you know I think
you can beat it it's obviously it's
obviously you're aware of it and that's
really the first step you know just try
and stay curious I think that'll help
you stay interested and good luck with
your job you sound you sound like uh
[ __ ] I'd read something you wrote I
think you know I mean I can't really
think about your writing through your
talking but [ __ ] if you just did some
dang graffiti I used to read graffiti
you know and some of it was pretty damn
educational a lot of it was just about
people you know [ __ ] mostly anyhow
onward
yo Socky oh this is Brian from
Philadelphia Philadelphia Brian let's go
I have a question for you I really need
some advice you ever talks [ __ ] on
someone and texted it to that person
when it is meant to go to another person
basically I talk [ __ ] on my stepmom and
I render send it to my brother but I
went to my stuff
he got really pissed Wow oh did I feel
for you right when you say that Brian
here we talk [ __ ] on his stepmom instead
of texting it to his brother he texted
it to his stepmom oh and that's such a
crucial position too because oh you got
to see here it's just man that's heavy
bro have I ever done that I'll tell you
really quickly yes I have I met a girl
who was like my dream girl you know and
I mean I of course I fantasized that I
romanticized it I didn't even know her
but I wanted to know her and I started
like putting it out there like I want to
know where I want to know where I want
to know where outs here a few weeks in a
row and I finally got her phone number
well that same day some like skis had
hit me up on I think on snapchat and was
sending me like nudes and stuff you know
or something or saying new you know
saying naughty stuff to me so I gave
that girl on snapchat my number you know
I mean I've there's no law that I've you
know I've get suffer from you know
temptation and getting caught up in
pornography and some of the DA's baby
the dark arts so I gave that girl my
number well then I also that same day
got the number of the girl that I really
thought was a special chick so later
that night the oh and right whenever I
got the special girls number I texted
her and I said I'm gonna I said hey it's
Theo and she didn't text me back
immediately or anything that's fun well
later that night I get a text and it
says I'm gonna put you in my phone
that's what the text said right and I
thought it was from this girl on
snapchat this straight you know snaps
Kesey that I just give him my number too
so I wrote back like oh well you can put
me anywhere you want right so then the
girl writes back oh really this is
interesting tell me more right and so I
start just getting turning into a
straight pervert well about two two
texts later from each of us I realize
that this is the girl that
I admit that I really liked and then I
had texted her she had just written back
to me you know a few hours later I'm
gonna put you in my phone and I didn't I
just didn't correlate it in my mind I
was just maybe perved out or something I
don't know and man that was god that
hurts so much because now I'm like
already such a creep to this girl that I
just met that I really liked but it
ended up working out where I got to you
know started to get to know that girl
and she gave me a second chance so that
was really it was really beautiful
but let's hear it let's hear the rest of
your story I'm sorry for rambling and
then make matters worse it was my
birthday and I said maybe I should go
they said no and I opened my birthday
presents in silence and I also ate the
birthday cake in silence total silence
so now my dad is saying it's going to
take some time and I don't know really
where to go from here so if you have any
advice contact him well I appreciate you
reaching out man I just appreciate you
sharing this story man this is a real
story and I love it and I can feel your
layers of pain there cuz you're probably
upset you know you and we say things
when we're upset that you know we we
exaggerate and your stepmom read this
stuff and she's already an uphill battle
as a stepmom and she's probably not that
bad of a stepmom I have no idea but
step-parenting seems like straight hell
I mean step parenting is basically in an
invite to probably be sued by a kid and
here she is working her butt you know
whatever but obviously they gave you
gifts and you they gave you this cake
and you're sitting there in silence bro
dude that silent cake you was eating
that silent cake and what's that thing
where they say you have to eat your
what's it's like an old saying you got
to eat your thumb you got to eat your I
don't know what it is dude but I got no
advice man your dad's right it's gonna
take time
you know you
free you know you got busted ooh you got
busted Street being a straight regular
person and sometimes we get busted being
a regular person man
just being human that's what you got
busted being you got busted being honest
you got busted being human
now if there's some real stuff behind
some of those texts you sent now this
might be a good opportunity to address
some of those things with her you know
but outside of that if you're just like
you know damn Martha's got the saggy
tits in town then that [ __ ] hang on play
well duh you know wow I can just picture
somebody sitting there eating that
silent cake just hearing their mouths
hit it and it probably couldn't even
enjoy it because of how just how much
you had ruined Martha's day or whatever
her name is Margaret or not even tell me
your name could be a Nadia she could be
Spanish but while bro look dude it's
things are happening man you know it
could be global warming maybe that's why
you're screwing up like that and texting
the wrong people but we've all been
there you know we've all been there and
happy Labor Day to you do because that
sounds like a real labor of love right
there and that's maybe something that
everybody's going through with some of
these labors of love you know I think
that's something that everybody's having
to deal with here and there it's just
you know it's hard being in love is hard
staying in love is hard figuring it out
fighting to stay in love fighting to
keep these relationships to to not [ __ ]
it up you know to keep communication
open [ __ ] as hell dude and the skies are
opening up dude and mother nature is
about to bust nuts that's what I'm
thinking but well you know what dude
what the hell do I know you know I'll
tell you this last thing about Labor Day
and then uh I'm gonna get out of here I
got a set at The Comedy Store in 21
minutes but I'll tell you this man I got
when I got laid off from that pizza
joint here's how I got laid off so they
had me and this other dude they had
another guy that worked up there that
was mentally challenged and he was uh I
don't know what he had he had a
something
they don't even have anymore I don't
even know what it was and he was also
his parents for both of them were kind
of like wiggers you know and I used the
term wiggler I don't mean in a racially
offensive way but you know what I'm
talking about they were wiggers and he
that his parents would dress him up all
would wiggle him up
you know they had his ears pierced and
they had him in all these Detroit
Pistons [ __ ] and he was mentally
challenged you know and I've always had
a special spot in my heart for the
mentally challenged because I've always
felt I've always felt a little bit
mentally challenged you know at my core
or that I just beat it you know I've
always felt that I just beat a couple of
diseases you know or a couple of mental
challenges just beat him you know I
didn't get first place I didn't get the
blue ribbon and get him but I got second
place runner-up to a lot of mental
challenges but anyhow me and him would
do these contests where we would put our
head under the dish water for as long as
we could and the dish water was dirty
and you'd hold your head down there for
as long as you could to try and be the
champ and the champ was whoever held
their head under the dish water the
longest so I remember putting my head
under that dish water one time and he'd
just done about I think 28 seconds and I
would let him cheat a little bit because
the guy is mentally challenged you know
I don't even know if he could swim I
don't even know what his aquatic skills
are you know as an adult or a man I can
hold he was he could have been anywhere
from 16 to probably 28 he had a mustache
and he had like another mustache kind of
on one of his cheeks he was you know a
lot of his growth and everything was
awry wasn't natural patterns he wasn't
you know he wasn't showing a lot of
natural hair patterns but anyhow so I
put my head under that dishwater dude um
down there bro and you could feel the
oil like a lot of times you'd come up
and you never ring of that dirty
dishwater that oil and the grease from
it from the pizza pans would just be
around your neck you know and a lot of
times we would do this when the boss was
next door at the pool hall drinking so I
have my head down there and I'm just
catching time brother
I mean I'm putting in time baby you know
like I'm just you know I'm doing a
couple life sentences under this
and I think I'm up near a minute and I
pull my head out and I'm just like I'm
the champ you know and the boss was
right there and he fired me so you know
I guess I don't even know what the moral
of the story is I don't think it matters
but bottom line is sometimes the champ
gets fired
sometimes the champ gets caught you know
sometimes you're the champ
and you get busted and that's what's
happening to people that's what's
happened in this dude getting busted
texting his mother you know that's
what's happening in the gal that's
judgmental she's thinking she's the
champ but now she's realizing that that
she's coming in second place because
she's being so judgmental that's what's
gonna happen to this dude that wants to
challenge me on that basketball court
for the charity hustle he's gonna be
second place you know he's gonna be
realized that he he got beat by someone
who barely beat down syndrome and other
diseases and probably some other popular
afflictions that ISM and all of that you
know you got people wanting to be the
champ and coming in second place you got
a man that ran right into a fire out
there at Burning Man ran right into a
fire trying to be the champ and now he
came in second place but I bet he
hopefully went to heaven you know and
hopefully at his funeral they'll fill
him with bacon and they'll put some
julienned potatoes around his body in
that casket you know maybe some walk a
MOLLE and some chips something to
fine-tune him something to help us snack
while he's on his way up to heaven you
know or we celebrate his life so hit the
hotline if you got some things going on
this has been a Labor Day episode kind
of a calm episode but I appreciate the
support so much we hit our highest
listening totals last week and I haven't
really felt like - these last week and
this week I've even been my favorite
episodes you know but I'm just trying to
be a part of what's going on I'm trying
to show up for you guys and and I and
I'm open to great ideas we're gonna keep
evolving here we're gonna have the
patreon up this week where you can be a
part of it and we're just going to keep
celebrating living man we're gonna learn
as we go
I want to thank Spencer Jacob gray who
came out who wrote this
and who plays this song and he donates
this song to our show and you can catch
his music online the link is on the
YouTube page you can see the new set on
the YouTube page as well and and thank
you for supporting this past weekend I
love you y'all made me feel better my
feeling horrible the beginning of this
not horrible but just get frustrated man
you know when you took when you cut a
neon balls you you start questioning
yourself we did it
[Music]
we did it man y'all be good to
yourselves man but you guys deserve it
I'll see you in Austin Texas this
weekend if you got friends that live
there in Austin tell them to come on out
and if somebody's destitute or having
some tough times let them know I'm happy
to get them some tickets if you have
friends that are that have been
displaced because of Houston that are
gonna be in Austin this weekend that
could use a night of laughter let me
know hit me up on Twitter
hit me up email me at Theo van at matcom
and let me see what I can do to try and
help out I can't promise everybody but a
couple of people I can probably help out
so you guys be good huh let's keep this
[ __ ] up baby I love you [ __ ] North
Korea boy bout to get that ass what I'll
see you guys in heaven all right